Why Salt Preserves Meat
While today salting meat as a method of preservation
is generally only commonly used in such things
as salted pork and the like, salt has been
used as the primary method of preserving meats
and various other foods as far back as history
records.
Salt has a preservative effect thanks to the
osmotic pressure it creates via absorption.
For example, if you take a red blood cell
and place it in water, thanks to osmotic pressure
and the fact that the cell membrane is thin
and semipermeable, the cell with its relatively
salty interior next to the pure water will
gradually absorb more and more water until
it explodes.
On the flipside, if you place that same red
blood cell into water that is saltier than
the cell’s interior liquid, the reverse
will happen and the cell will gradually lose
water, shriveling up in the process.
Place it in water that has the same sodium
level as the cell, and nothing at all will
happen.
This same effect will happen with most mold
and microbes.
So if you use the salt for its absorption
effect to increase the osmotic pressure, these
things that may spoil the meat will have trouble
surviving and reproducing as their moisture
is sucked from them.
The more salt added to the item (or sugar,
which has the same effect and is often used
to help get around the strong salt flavor),
the longer the preservative effect will last.
You can also observe this absorption effect
simply by taking some cotton candy and placing
it in a humid environment.
With just 33% relative humidity, cotton candy
left out in the air will completely collapse
and crystallize in just 3 days as it absorbs
the moisture in the air.
At 45% relative humidity, it will completely
collapse in just one day.
At 75% humidity, it takes just 1 hour.
This is why it has only been since 1972 that
non-”made on demand” cotton candy has
been available.
(1972 was when the first fully automated cotton
candy machine was invented that could make
the fluffy treat and quickly package it in
water tight containers).
If you’re wondering how to salt meat for
preservation, the process is fairly simple
and straightforward, though there are a variety
of variations on the basic method used to
improve flavor.
In general, you simply rinse the fresh meat
in cold or lukewarm water, then pour a thin
layer of salt (generally kosher salt) all
over the meat and rub it in.
Next, hang or set the meat out in a cool environment
(under 60 degrees Fahrenheit, but not below
freezing) for a couple weeks to dry it out
a bit.
Finally, before cooking the meat, rinse off
the salt with water.
In theory, if you use enough salt or sugar
when doing this, you can even preserve meat
for decades, though of course the amount you’d
have to use would probably make it unpalatable.
At the minimum, if you’re only using salt
or sugar with no other preservative method
like smoking or the like, it’s generally
considered that about a 20% salt concentration
on the surface of the meat is needed to kill
off most types of microbes and fungi that
can spoil food quickly.
Bonus Facts:
• In the 18th century, salted beef or horse
meat (usually low quality) eaten on sailing
vessels as part of daily rations was called
“salt junk” or just “junk”, making
it technically the first food item called
“junk food”.
Around a century later “junk” had spread
to refer to anything of low quality, though
it wouldn’t be until around the 1970s that
people would commonly start calling certain
food items low in nutritional value “junk
food”.
• Pickling meat and other items usually
uses a salt/acidic method to achieve preservative
effects, often using some sort of vinegar
for the acidic element, which further creates
an environment that most microbes and fungi
have trouble surviving in.
The most popular commercially available item
that still uses this technique is pickles.
This is usually done by first soaking cucumbers
in a salt water brine (generally about 10%
salt) for a few days, then rinsing the cucumbers
off with purified water.
Next, placing the cucumbers in vinegar and
sealing them in airtight jars.